hello everyone for the afternoon session
so we have eva agreed to present uh
a tutorial on uh
learning uh
as a solution concept
and eva will sort of pick up a bit from
where uh kostas left off on uh no regret
learning in general some games is going
to be talking about quality of outcomes
when people use learning in games
trying to see whether the pros and cons
of using
learning theoretic solution concepts in
general games
and hopefully that will be uh that will
set some foundations for
the second the third workshop that we're
going to have on learning in in the
presence of strategic behavior
thank you and
hi everyone it's so nice to see you guys
or at least
you know at least
in part from a distance
i'm really sorry i'm not actually there
physically
unfortunately my plan for the semester
was
to
travel to
berkeley a couple of times or maybe
multiple times and
hopefully sooner or later that's going
to be still possible i'm sorry that with
the current covet level
i
that uncomfortable
doing this right now um
i guess i'm doing this online and
well i sort of see a little picture of
all of you on my screen
it's not that big
so i would suggest that actually just
speaking up if you have a question that
would be
really
the simplest way to go
um
if
someone over there wants to
warn me that one of you raised a hand
and i'm not noticing it please do
um
and as promised again uh
uh
vassal vaseli subjected uh selected the
title for for what i should talk about
um so here it is
i added this in repeated games as a
subtitle
uh and i took the
this is a
boot camp um
very seriously as in trying to really do
a background of what is it that
would be useful to to know
for the workshop or generally for
participation in a lot of different
activities so you know many of you might
know a lot of this and i apologize if
this is a repeat for many participants
uh here is an outline of the kind of
things i want to talk about during the
next two hours
um
so the general question is indeed as as
was promised examples of games and
question the question we want to ask and
i guess i want to ask two questions
uh overall
one what do we
mean by learning and what can we say
about learning outcomes
um
mostly
which is maybe not quite the
continuation of what uh
kostas was talking about
i want to view or want to think about or
like thinking about learning as a
behavioral assumption
and not
uh and as such uh it's not focusing or i
try not to focus on
particular learning algorithms that
maybe do better but rather
properties of that
that learners might achieve such as the
no regret property
and then what can we do to
prove
if everyone achieves those kind of
properties
uh i'm not
definitely not vetted to the no regret
property as the only possible assumption
here and i think
a definitely very interesting question
uh
if we can make
uh more realistic or better assumptions
and use that use those to prove stronger
things
but i guess it list what i'm most
interested in and what i more want to
talk about is assumptions of this form
that you can make and that helps you
prove stuff
rather than concrete uh designing or
naming concrete algorithms that do well
in particular setup
again it seems
more realistic to assume that
uh learners will satisfy
some of these assumptions or some
assumptions rather than assuming that
they particularly use our favorite
learning algorithm or whatever the
learning algorithm that
we can use in the proof
um
so quality of no regret outcome not
learning outcomes is this sort of
generalization of price of energy um
but i also want to talk about
um limitations i guess this next bullet
point does indeed overlap with what
kostas was talking about so i might cut
that a little bit short
uh
and i guess the last bullet here that no
regret sometimes makes us do the wrong
thing or is the wrong assumption that's
more of an open question
than uh actual results and in these
directions i can show you some
uh extensions of price of energy results
using different versions of learning
but some again some many of this is more
what i hope
uh some of you or some of us will
try working on during the semester
uh again please do interrupt me with any
comments and questions
so again what i'm going to focus on is
repeating games and my two
favorite repeated game is traffic
wrapping where
the
thing that you're you're um
uh repeating is
cars or packets or little things uh
choosing paths in a in a network where
which is congestion sensitive and
uh
more traffic uh
causes delays and an alternate one which
i guess is maybe more or many of you or
many people work on these auctions
advertising auction is maybe the killer
application of these repeated games that
definitely an important application
um
advertising
space
is usually not very expensive
per item but uh the the interest or the
value is the insane number of
repetitions
uh a model repeated game as a you know
there's a time horizon every step every
player takes some sort of action and
then something happens and they repeat
this time over and over again uh we go
i'm going to throughout make the
assumption that players value or costs
are additive over period that is
um
they aiming to minimize
the average cost or maximize the average
utility or something
of this simple form and again there are
excellent questions here with
interesting other objective functions
that they
uh might want to use and again want to
assume that they somehow learn doing
this learning from past data and
the the
questions you want to ask is what can we
say about
the outcome of this and
and what does it mean to learn from data
um
you know i guess an older beginning of
all this research is
actually not using learning just what is
usually called equilibrium analysis that
is looking at nash equilibria of game
and
i guess it's sort of
nice to start any uh price of energy
style quality or
quality value analysis
with just
reminding you that over the last 20
years or actually more
between 2099
and
say early
early about 10 years ago there was a lot
of different results about price of
energy on starting with nash equilibria
so i guess here is some version with
uh tim roughgarden is relatively early
about traffic writing which maybe many
of you know
is
you know that the
cost of a nash equilibrium in a traffic
routing example
is no worse than
the
cost of a socially designed optimum
traffic pattern that has to carry twice
as much traffic
um again i'll come back to this but nash
equilibrium is a solution where no
player
has incentive to deviate and technically
the price of energy was defined in this
cost of financial equilibrium defi
divided by
uh
cost of an optimal optimally designed
solution
um the results we proved here have these
sort of small constant factors like the
factor of two in there which hopefully
you're going to view as a as a positive
this is as opposed to
the tragedy of the commons where the
answer would be that the social redesign
optimal solution has high value but when
selfish users
uh
put cash on a shared uh resource then
unlike the pictures suggest uh there
will be so many casts that the value
will go to zero so there is a
not a small factor of two but then
large factor factor
uh again there are lots of results here
and i'm not going to either go through
them or
or
or
maybe show you one example but not focus
on the price of energy analysis because
that is not the general focus of this of
this uh this uh
special semester or or the topic i'm
going to mostly talk about but there are
lots of results
some of them are bandwidth sharing or
traffic writing and also lots of results
on auctions
again all involving some small constant
like you lose a factor of two or one and
a half or something like that
um
again
the main question is what happens if
people are learning and i guess
uh
starting with really early history
which i guess i should not uh
we don't want to spend a ton of time on
but it's nice to start with
uh
it was started in i guess early 50s
which has the
uh ancient age to it that it's before i
was born
by brown and robinson who were thinking
about something called uh fictitious
play that is people best responding to
the part of the history
and in fact one focus which is maybe
part of what kostas was also talking
about or maybe not um was thinking of
learning as a pre-play that is uh
i hope that that
learning uh converges to converges to an
equilibrium solution and nash
equilibrium uh i guess this is what
uh many of the costas results were about
um
that is that if you ever participates
that's learning
or results that cost us reviewed very
bad uh
if every participate part does learning
then the system converges to uh
equilibrium so this is really useful if
you use learning as a training
and i guess there are many applications
where this training is what learning is
for you do a training phase and
hopefully
i guess as his example shows you learn
to recognize faces or whatever the task
is
but in general games this isn't working
out so well that is
learning does not actually converge to
a nash equilibrium and i guess uh
there are very few results and i guess
one class that customs did talk about is
two plus and zero some games
uh but mostly that's sort of the big
class where this works and generally
doesn't
um
so
um
okay i just noticed that someone posted
on the chat window is are the slides
posted unfortunately i didn't post them
ahead of time but more than happy to
share them after the talk i'm sorry
um
okay so
you know
if if this isn't working as a pre-player
at least not in many games
uh and many interactions it isn't the
learning phase that learning is about
it's learning as part of the
the the activity itself like you know
as you're running an auction
at auction
um the participants constantly learn
it's not like they learn and then they
done but they non-stop learn
then we want a different notion and
that's what this presentation will be
about
so
um
i guess i'm going to think of
uh
you know when learning converges we sort
of view that it looks like this
they initially do something and then
either they literally land on a nash
equilibrium or at least get super close
to it and nash equilibrium is a set of
actions a is the property that you know
no one wants to deviate which i guess is
the no regret property again what this
notation says that the cost of
cost of
uh
what the player i observes
in this action vector a
is less or less than or equal than any
other cost he can singlehandedly
generate by switching his part of the
action to x like everyone else stays
with this action and he switches to x
and then apparently that costs even
even more or at least no less that's no
regret property and that's an important
property
uh that's what it means to be at nash
equilibrium
um
showing you for a second data from uh
this point
more than six-year-old paper
of dennis
denis nikita and
it's like
there are lots of things that don't
stabilize and i guess advertisement
search on
on
bing that is
microsoft system
is one of the things and we have a sort
of bunch of data
uh in that paper that we analyzed that
hey look it's not actually converging to
nash equilibrium and we even offer that
actually we know why uh what these guys
do is use some sort of learning
algorithm when they're there these
companies that help or at the time these
are companies from
those years that help the advertisers uh
sort of place the ads well so
okay the main message here and i you
know that's where i really want to sort
of my starting point of what i want to
talk about
is this change of focus instead of
thinking of
learning as a pre-play where the goal is
that it converges to something i want to
think about
as a activity itself like people
constantly learn and constantly do stuff
and they're learning
while they're playing
and
if you want you can even think of it as
a you know infinitely repeated game
where
a participant will show up after
at some point at that point he or she or
his company doesn't know quite what to
do but experiments a bit and then you
know after they played for long enough
they know what they're doing um
and they have they satisfy some say they
use a learning algorithm or satisfy some
sort of property
the easiest property to use as promised
by
the abstract or the intro is the no
regret property so remember no regret
for the nash equilibrium was this so the
cost of
what the player i plays is no worse than
the cost of any other action that this
player could do given that other people
not changing their strategies
and then the no regret property
without assuming the convergence would
mean this
that
the cost of
what a player gets over time summing
over all the periods is no worse than
and that's a sort of simple particularly
simple version of of of the property
that will turn out very achievable or
you know is very achievable is a single
strategy with hindsight that is had he
consistently done this strategy x
then
that would have been even more expensive
because there is an upfront learning
phase and you can't expect that the
player is knowledgeable right in the
beginning i guess we should allow a
little bit of regret error and as kostas
already talked about what are the
achievable regret errors in a general
verse case setting uh what usually is
the root t after t periods assuming the
costs are in the zero one range the
overall error is uh something like root
t
uh
is what's achievable in the worst case
for simple learning algorithms
uh there are tons of those uh i guess
multiplicativates is something that
kostas talked about follow the per third
leader has a has a
some advantages
but again very simple and i'm not going
to elaborate what those what these
algorithms are um
use the fact that this is a reasonable
property
um
i can
offer you two comments one of which sort
of cl clearly connects to what kostas
was talking about and the other one
is maybe
goes in two different different
directions what kostas offered one sense
i want to be not so sensitive to the
error and i'm willing to say that as
long as it doesn't grow linearly with t
that is close in little of the less than
linearly i
guess i call that as an acceptable error
so again root t is something that i'm
achievable by the simple algorithms but
again i might not want to be so
sensitive
but maybe in some places i do actually
want to be sensitive and then from the
price of
price of energy perspective i actually
prefer a different version of these
bands so if you're willing to give me
a little bit of a multiplicative leeway
that is the classical no regret
guarantee band
you're comparing to the cost
and there is no multiplier in front of
the cost if i'm so it's an a pure
additive band if i'm willing to go a
little bit multiplicative say instead of
purely
just an additive error i give you an one
plus epsilon multiplier on the cost
and then an additional little bit of an
additive error then it turns out that
uh with epsilon within one plus epsilon
multiplicative error then the epsilon
the effect of the epsilon that the
additive error is log the dimension or
the number of strategies divided by
epsilon
uh
if you have seen
sort of classical analysis of
multiplicative eight or follow the
protometer they get the rooty band by
first getting my kind of band the one i
just gave you is the epsilon and
uh then choosing the best epsilon
uh
given these parameters in a worst case
sense and that works out to be
this band epsilon should be
uh
log d over root of log b over t
uh but i actually would propose and i'll
come back to this uh
in a couple in a few slides that at
least for the price of energy style
analysis i might actually not want this
and i might want to just keep an ex
explicit epsilon and error tolerance
into
in my uh my bands because
uh
this makes the error term significantly
smaller so in fact we'll make the
convergence or the number of times
needed times number of steps needed for
learning to occur much much faster
and
a little bit of multiplicative error is
not going to harm
at least the price of energy bands
significantly so again i'll come back to
this and the moment is just a reminder
that
or maybe a fact that hopefully many of
you know and seen that as you do the
classical analysis for either of these
algorithms uh that rooty is coming from
a trade-off between
choosing the best epsilon
uh optimizing these two terms and maybe
i want to not do that and just leave
epsilon as a constant small constant for
now
okay so
as kostas actually mentioned
uh
if everyone does
no regret learning and again
i won't actually care about what form of
no regret learning then what happens is
that the play will converge to not to
nash equilibrium but to a form of
correlated equilibrium
in limit in the limit as number of times
goes to infinity
the error term vanishes and
uh
the distribution
what happens is the expected payoff is
by definition is greater than expected
payout for any fixed strategy with
hindsight
i guess in two-person zero-sum games
this means that
uh
the it turns out as was proven by rob
and rob for um
friend and
shapira and sort of similar to the
robinson proof in a different somewhat
different uh definitions
that it convert that the game
converges to the value of the nash
equilibrium that is the players get the
right value but i want to point out the
game will they play will correlate that
is it's not the case that they converge
to
a
distribution of the nash equilibrium and
i guess a nice example to see this is is
a rock paper scissor
where
you know even if you start off with a
nash equilibrium
if
you know accidentally i play rock a
little bit more heavily or more often
than i should then the learning
algorithm of my opponent will know that
oh she's playing rock all the time paper
beats rock so i should more emphasize
paper and
and and so on then once i uh the
opponent emphasizes paper then i
realized that okay scissor is a good id
and we end up with this six cycle that
is very that's much more heavily played
than the
the
diagonal entries
uh which in particular means that the
value is right but our play is not the
nash equilibrium play it just has just
happens to have the right value
so
of course if accidentally uh
we play independently then what we're
doing is the nash but what happened is
that we're not actually playing
independently we're correlating
um so this is not only for two-person
for zero-sum games though the nash
equilibrium connection is but instead
uh in any game if everyone does no
regret learning then in the limit
they're going to converge to something
that again literally by definition
satisfies this property that the cost
for player i on average is greater than
uh oops this inequality is backwards i'm
really sorry we'll fix it
uh before releasing the slides but the
cost is
is no less than no no greater than any
fixed strategy with hindsight
uh that's like the nash equilibrium
except that it correlates
and again
uh the idea is that because
people
playing
uh looking at the very same shared
history then that uh correlate that they
get them correlated uh the same way as
how they got correlated in the
two-person zero-sum games
um
you know my play depends on the
opponent's play and we're both sort of
reacting to our chef history um
so
maybe
i'm going to
spend a minute here just sort of
summarizing where i what i want to think
of as the sort of main message i want to
think of no regret as a
satisfying the no regret as a as a
behavioral property
that is again i just repeated what i
meant by no regret i prefer this version
with the epsilon
it's
i want to think of this as i don't care
what algorithms they use as long as
whatever they did satisfies this
property then they satisfy no regret as
a behavioral model
this idea of thinking of nouright as a
behavioral model was first suggested by
a paper of blonde hagyati liguette and
ross in the context of traffic routing
and then a little bit tiny bit later but
still the same year kista do kovac and
shapira in the context of auctions
uh in both cases they're proving nice
properties of what happens when all the
players satisfy this
as a property
i like it for many reasons
um
in particular because it somehow feels
okay in in as a behavioral assumption
if there is a consistently good strategy
please notice it so if there is this
strategy x
that's
better than your strategy that is if you
fail this then please wake up to this
fact
that is something a decent learning
algorithm should
observe
i put in a couple of pros and cons in
the next slide of why what's good about
it and i guess the process may be
something you guys all know because
there have been a lot of work in this
area uh the cons are something that
i think you might want to think about as
the semester proceeds of you know what
we might want to do about it so i guess
the cons
um
there are many simple rules that achieve
it as i already mentioned
it is nice to notice that unlike other
game theoretic models there is no need
for on prior they don't
they
you know the players don't have to know
who's who they're playing against or
what the game exactly is or what might
be the right strategy they just learn
from data and example duo
and i guess maybe the top one that i
started with
that i didn't say yet but i definitely
love it it's a behavioral model it's a
nice mathematical description it's very
usable as a in doing theory
uh
but unfortunately there are some
negatives also
and here are a few negatives
um
i'll cut back to this but it's not
always doable like i give you
nice examples of or algorithms that
achieve this but
as i'll come back to this in a bit in
some settings
especially multi-parameter problems the
running times of this algorithm or the
aggregate regret bands are
prohibitively high and i guess the
parameter that i didn't emphasize
over there uh was and maybe
um
verse paging back to it so it takes a
while of paging sorry
is that that letter d there uh d is the
number of different bits achievable
possible that is the number of the
strategy space
and some games have very big strategies
bases or even possibly infinite strategy
bases so we have to be a little bit
careful with
what's achievable
um
it is reasonable to ask and i don't have
a good answer to that if i lift the game
to
you know you and i playing against each
other we both entering a learning
algorithm
then we actually have a different game
on which our strategies are learning
algorithms or any kind of algorithms and
you can ask is playing no regret
learning a nash equilibrium of this
learning game and the answer is probably
not uh so that's definitely an
interesting and lots of interesting
questions there of
you know if if we played played this as
a
i play a learning game against other
people playing learning games what is
the nash equilibrium of this game i
don't even know the answer to this
question if i limit everyone to play
multiplicative weight
and the only thing i allow you to change
is the parameters of your multiplicative
weight algorithm what's the equilibrium
of that game
and then of course maybe the biggest
issue is the last bullet on this point
is that and now that's what i'm going to
end with in the next hour is uh
there are many reasons that no regret is
literally seems like the wrong thing to
do
um
and
um
you know even give giving advice to
people of what might be the good good
out good thing to play or what might be
a good model of learning behavior
something that we believe that people or
learners or learning algorithms tend to
achieve
but it's a different property than no
regret
i think it's an important
open direction which i hope this
semester will give
some progress on
there are some papers that try to think
about or look at data or is it a decent
behavior model
i guess one of which is the paper denis
and i had denis and vasily and i had
that i already showed you some data from
some of them are
human subject experiments i'm not going
to maybe go through all the data
i guess uh
maybe verse pointing out that you know
it
it seems like advertisement data
it's reasonably consistent i guess about
30 of the bidders have literally no
regret or maybe even negative regret
that is they did better than the
benchmark and
a large part of it is not much regret so
a little bit of error
the context of this paper was which is
another direction that would be
interesting to do more during the
semester is
is econometrics that is trying to infer
people's values from the behavior uh
classical econometrics likes using the
nash equilibrium as an assumption that
is assuming that the play is at nash
equilibrium which in particular would
mean
that
uh you know if if the bits are changing
that must be because your values keep
changing all the time and i personally
much prefer the assumption that
maybe the environment's a little bit
changing and you're slowly adopting it
we are learning but it's not like your
values are jumping up and down
like crazy
um
so i
you know this is sort of the intro part
on talking about what i mean by learning
and i guess uh it came with
maybe one important message or a pair of
important messages and the difference
between what what kostas was talking
about i'm not going to talk about what
is the bad map best ways to learn learn
to play in a game instead i want to
focus on
and they're very simple assumptions such
as the no regret assumption what what
can we say about the game outcomes
if all the players satisfied this
assumption so i prefer to think of it
not as an algorithm but as a behavioral
assumption
and uh i don't know
if there are any questions about this
intro part
then this is a good moment to ask
could i elaborate on the parameter d
um
can i uh
so the
the the easiest games i was thinking
about is give us the number of
strategies that the players have so
i guess in a in the traffic routing you
can say that well it's a graph
uh on you know some number of notes and
edges
uh the
the
number of strategies is all possible
pass from the source to the destination
so that's
exponential in the
in the
uh
parameters of the of
of the problem that is the graph size
uh
luckily the regret bond only has log d
in it so that means that the regret is
proportional to the graph size
which might be unfortunate on big graphs
that might not be ideal
life is much much worse
in
in multi-dimensional actions
so
step number one and i'll we'll come back
to this in a second uh you have to
discretize the space because i guess i
can beat
if i can beat any real number then the
space is infinite
but with a little bit of error tolerance
one can discretize the space of bits and
say you can only bid or i will only be
at multiples of some epsilon or you know
one cent
uh but if i can bid on multiple items i
have to make this decision on the large
range of things on all the possible
items
and that's actually a very large
configuration space so again a huge
amount of error uh
comes in
uh because there's so many things
and i guess just remember
just legally remember how these
algorithms actually work
uh in they all based on the explore
exploit strategy so i guess you have to
try all your options
and you
know beat all kinds of crazy things and
see how that they work uh this explore
part will take an insanely long time
because you have to keep trying stuff
so
uh there is something
uh problematic
and how this will work
um
so with that i'm going to to go
to the sort of
second part of the main thing i want to
present is the price of energy so
quality of learning outcomes
looking at this price of energy he
started with a
99 paper of papadimity kotsupia sampaopu
dimitrio
who defined it as i already had it on
the earlier slide the cost of
the cost of a
nash equilibrium or the worst possible
nash equilibrium compared to some
century design optimum
the main message that i'm going to start
with and we'll cover
is that
if everyone is a no regret learner then
we can express this
in a
you can think of an extension which i
will also call a price of energy though
originally that
has some variant on the name to this
where you look at the very same thing on
average cost over time i guess in this
case the limit as time goes to infinity
the average cost overall cost that all
the players incurred divide by
the optimum which is i guess over t
periods is d times the individual
optimum
so this under the assumption that all
the players are no regret learners again
i said i said that the first
paper that suggested to this was blam
hog
and ross
uh
and uh tim rovgarden did a beautiful
elegant very general reduction which
basically saying that
almost always or at least the classical
proofs of price of energy automatically
extend to this case and maybe i'm going
to do a short summary of why that was
and then
you know there will be some further
extensions that is still possible
i guess one also at this point more than
five years so result is
uh
is uh todoris vasilyan and neon
even true as player dynamic population
games that is in game says enter and
leave the leave the
the playing area
still if they're learners then they can
the price of energy band remains the
same or is not so much worse
so here is team's framework which is
something that gets used a lot and if
you haven't seen or maybe forgot then
this is a useful reminder to think about
how this works
and i'm going to try to do this
uh both at the high level
uh in a way that sort of easiest to
make it very believable that oh yeah
something like this better be true
uh or easily true and also maybe give
you one example just to get a sense of
for the sake of how this is useful
um
so i guess the
the
only assumption that we will use in the
proof is
for one special strategy for example
whatever the optimum might want you to
do that if you're in nash equilibrium
you're in your player i you do not
prefer to
switch to that strategy let's call it ai
star is your action that you would do at
this centrally designed optimum and you
actually as player i prefer
uh what you're doing right now that's
you know a very special version of the
nash condition
and then these proofs work at a funny
looking inequality which team called
london use smooth which says that the
cost of
summing over these funny quantities that
is mixed quantities that player ice
crossed if he alone would switch to the
century design optimum while everyone
else stays at a should always be
satisfied this inequality should be less
than some lambda times the optimum plus
mu times the current cost it looks like
a weird inequality
but it certainly was easy to convince
you that this is useful and maybe also
that
there is a sort of natural meaning
behind it
and
the way i want to think about why is it
useful is if you currently have a
solution that's very very expensive so
if at the solution a you're at that's
insanely
expensive
then what this
inequality is trying to say is that hey
one of you will want to deviate
so if the overall cost is very high then
some player's cost is high
and
this possible deviation thinking of one
deviation for everyone
is
is uh
uh
summing to be a low number so one of you
must have a
a lower alternate cost so why is this
slow lambda times optimum lambda is
hopefully a small constant so the
optimum is much much smaller so even
love that times optimum is smaller and
then the assumption up here is that this
parameter mu is below one so
hopefully this would mean if you're a
very high cost that
what's in the right hand side
is less than the cost of the current
solution so
one of you must want to deviate or
putting it differently if you're a nash
equilibrium then
uh i guess by the nash condition
uh the current cost is less and i can
simply use this by rearranging energy
inequalities and then so that meshech
will review
the cost which is the green uh left hand
side
uh just rearranged a little bit is less
than lambda times one minus mu times the
optimum this is simply rearranging the
inequalities
so
i guess in english what it says that if
the cost is much much higher than the
optimum then this inequality forces that
someone we want will prefer to do is
optimal move and obviously that means
that the nash equilibrium must have low
cost so it's a sort of natural condition
but tim's
two
sort of key points of his observation is
was that
even though we have a lot of different
proofs they all actually had this
framework
um
maybe not observing that they're using
this framework
um
and also that
this is uh very naturally wants to
extend to learning outcomes
so remember learning.com
and i guess i use this epsilon version
learning adsense says that the total
cost the player observes is no worse
than the optimum cost times this little
bit of error plus some sort of error
parameter like regret approximate
learning regret
and then if the game is is london use
most then i can
use this inequality instead of the
national equality say that summing over
all the players this inequality we get
the sum
of the
sum of the costs over all the players is
less than uh
the alternate cost using the lambda mu
smoothness is less than
optimum plus the cost of these games and
again just like before we can rearrange
it and get an inequality about the
optimal
comparing the overall cost to the
optimum
uh
what i want to point out here is two
facts
one is
that compared to going back to the
previous slide where i had the error
or approximation by under lambda
divided by 1 minus mu if i allow this
epsilon in the learning parameter i get
a little bit of deterioration
both parameters get a little bit worse
by this epsilon
but not much worse so remember this
price of energy bands were constants
like you know 2 or 1.5 or something like
that so if you think that
a factor of 2 band is interesting then
i'm think factor of 2.1 is not that much
worse so
alloying an epsilon band here is really
very
tolerable
and
going back to that data that i showed
you about uh
learning in being
online advertising auctions
assuming that people learned with an
epsilon here something like five or ten
percent is a
much more
realistic assumption than that they
learned with a perfect error uh about 30
percent of the players had no error and
another 20 30 percent where the error
was below 10 percent so i think the the
small epsilon version of this is
probably a better behavioral assumption
that is more people satisfied
um
and it doesn't it badly hurts the price
of energy band just a tiny bit
um
it's also first pointing out what the
what the
what the error band is
uh and there i actually went back and
have a slide that sort of overlaps with
uh kind of things that
costas was talking about
so
the speed of how fast things converge
of course controlled by this error
parameter at the point where the error
is bigger than the optimum of course you
haven't converged and what you want this
error to be smaller than the optimum
to say that you're approximately there
um
the first kind of results in this
direction were um i guess as costas
todas and early eighties results by
popov i observed that this is happening
by uh early paper of costas with tech
obama and kim in
soda 11
and i guess my colleague kartik
shitharan had some versions these guys
are all using
specialized methods uh there is this
really beautiful paper by vasily and
company which extend this to general
games showing convergence
convergence results in is learning in
general games um
all of them
are using variations or at least at
least the later ones using specialized
method and in particular optimistic
optimistic
ah so not graduate sorry
uh
gradual descent algorithms uh this is
something uh
kostas talked about and was again in the
framework of trying to think of
algorithms that
speed convergence
i like our follow-up paper from the next
year which says that wait wait uh these
results are true without any assumption
and in fact even maybe
better error bands if
we all we have to assume is a behavioral
model that they're using no regret
algorithms they don't have to use any
specialized algorithm as long as i give
them a little bit of epsilon tolerance
in what they're supposed to achieve and
i guess the remember the error band for
this the epsilon version had this log d
over epsilon so we end up with a term
that's something like that and like it
says essentially a one over t band in it
which is the idea that
uh kostas was shooting for
at the price tag that i it i i'm more
aiming for the price of energy band and
not regret bonds and second uh that i
gave you an extra epsilon in the error
like allow you an extra epsilon in the
error
um
okay so
um i guess
i have a
maybe
10 more minutes before the break was
scheduled if i understand the scheduling
right and i guess i want to use this 10
more minutes to maybe
go back to somehow basics and actually
i've been using this
um or claiming that this price of energy
framework is
or smoothness framework is something
that
can be used and it's useful in general
but i guess i want some example to tell
you you know how this might work and my
example will be single item first price
auction because that's a super simple
thing to do
so what's a single item first price
auction
in the simple version there are these
players here and they want to bid on
this uh ugly looking camera sorry
and they all put in a price and i guess
because it's a first price option the
highest bidder events
if
that's the that's the first price
version
i guess
analyzing this
um
uh
as a full information game that assuming
everyone knows everything about all the
other people's values uh the highest
value bidder could have won
at the
bidding just a little bit above the next
highest price
this is not a very useful analysis so
this is a case where equilibrium
analysis is not very useful
because of you know this doesn't happen
in learning there's no reason anyone
would know the answer to this so that's
not a good analysis
um
and i guess one version that's sort of
nicer to think about is with some sort
of patient uncertainty that is you know
people's values are coming from
distributions there is this um
based on this they have to decide on
some bits
and then there is a random process and
in this case it's not possible to beat
right above the other person because you
don't know it
and
[Music]
and
so this is a better model or similarly
uh there could be a learning version
where they're trying to learn
so generally if i want to formulate an
auction game
um
sorry one second i need to check
something on my slide i apologize
uh what exactly happened here
oh good point nothing nothing wrong
sorry
you can go back
okay so as a general definition of
course it's not just one item the finite
set of players
um
players have can beat on some sets
uh
bidding on some items uh resulting in
some sort of strategy or action vector
of what they're building on each item
the players get utilities
uh
we can look at your slides we can only
view your oh i forgot to share my slides
that was a big problem thank you so much
for warning me
uh
let's go back
one more step back
yes
thank you
um
so generally it's like not have to be a
single item there are many items there
many players they're bidding on items
the bits can be anything
the assumption here is that use the same
notation as before except now it's
utility and not cost
and i guess one important fact that i'm
going to assume again to keep life
simple is that uh
there's quasi linear utility that is if
you get a set of items a you have some
value for this and minus the price
and what we're going to evaluate is
social welfare which is sum of all the
payers values which you can think of as
the utilities plus the auctioneer's
revenue
which counts towards welfare so that's
the general framework uh in case of a
single item auction which is where i was
coming from uh
is
this just means that the
the
social welfare is just the value of the
of the item who the person who won the
item
um
so here is a bid as a strategy function
um you did something
what makes it nash equilibrium is this
inequality and maybe it's worth spending
a minute to make sure we get the
notation here so a set of bits
uh is a nash equilibrium if for any
peter i conditioned on his value
uh the
the
the value or the utility he would get
out of this auction randomness taken
over the bids and randomness over the
other people's values which he doesn't
know is greater than had he beat
something else so he kept
everyone else behind the same but he is
uh bidding something else uh and this is
true for all possible other bits that's
what mesh equilibrium means
and i guess i want to end the current
version by giving you
a slightly different version of this
which is coming uh out of a paper of
uh
todoris vasily and myself
is
which is maybe better suited for action
games where is there instead of the
classical optimum plus something
plus cost we want to explicitly talk
about
uh
the
revenue that is the money as part of the
the
uh smoothness version that is we want to
say that something is smooth if there
would be special strategies like before
uh so that the
some the utilities of for any strategy
as switching to the special utilities is
greater than some lambda times the
optimum minus the revenue and i guess
this is just as good if not better for
uh social welfare for for the analysis
again just rearranging this inequality
the people's utilities
plus the revenue is what causes uh
it causes social welfare so it gives you
a price of energy of one over lambda now
i'm kind of running out of time maybe a
couple slides before when i wanted to
take the break but i guess uh
maybe what we should do is take a break
now
and
uh i'll come back to this slide and i
guess i'm going to stop sharing you have
five more minutes because we started uh
three minutes uh late if you wanna five
more minutes to finish something but
if you wanna post it's uh
i think it's i'm perfectly fine with
breaking here because that's the event
the break was scheduled and maybe the
food is available for you guys
uh and then
um you know it doesn't have much matter
whether i go over i plan to or just go
from here
it's fine with me
happy to take some questions and then
you know restart in 30 minutes thank you
very much everyone
yeah hello everybody so i i had just a
very general question about the
stability
of
bad players
do we know
anything about like
usually
um
you know stuff that you talked about are
like players following some rules
and let's say that if there is one
player that is not following the rules
the whole system is going to collapse or
so
again i don't want to think of it as
following rules as if they don't have to
play my favorite algorithm they should
just satisfy this no regret property um
there are some papers that that or
results which is actually not in my
summary right now or not in the plan of
the rest of the talk but there are few
places where
uh it is
reasonably easy to prove results of the
form that
as long as a large number of players are
no regret learners that is they do
satisfy the no regret property then we
get some welfare
like i guess in auction games
that is buying stuff
uh you know
if the optimal warfare involves
that i should uh
you know kostas should wake up the fact
that he values this item infinitely half
high
and he should beat high but kostas fell
asleep and forgot to bid
there's not much i can do about this
but uh
it it
statements of the firm that
the maximum social welfare achievable by
the people who are not regret learners
will be achieved or close to that will
be achieved by the system
so again
if somehow maximum welfare is very
heavily dependent on one person and i
picked costas but maybe in a more
classical version i should say uh you
know bill gates
but bill gates forgot to do it
there is not much i can do about that
uh but the statement that can be true
and is true in many games is that
in in utility games like auction games
is that the system will achieve a social
welfare
uh within this price of energy bank so
close to what would be achievable
by
the people who follow the norrigat
property i don't know what's up with the
other guys
so these are mostly true in utility
games which is nice
in games with costs
like as in traffic ratting
uh
there is a funny kind of problem if that
people who don't behave don't behave
as regret learners
the sole goal of those guys to create
congestion
that maybe they can create a fair amount
of congestion so it's harder to come up
with what are reasonable models of
what's achievable
and in that case because the people are
not not regret learners they could
actually be malicious
and malicious people can do all kinds of
crazy stuff
as in you know just driving circles and
creating congestion
again there is minimal amount of work
by
a couple papers that track
try to make some headway on this
but it is a little hard to
make sense of what might be doable here
so we'll take a break here and thank eva
and we'll have a 30-minute break and
we'll be back here again that's perfect
thank you
thanks everyone for tolerating me online